selena gomez is empowering her young
fans they're changing the world where
the next generation coming up ET caught
up with the singer at we day in Los
Angeles Thursday the event is a
star-studded celebration of youth making
a difference in their communities what
do you want to see your fans
specifically try and change like what's
important to you the dialogue you know
I'm very lucky that I have the platform
i have but on social media it's as much
as it's a blessing and it's fun it it
can really tear people down and I always
hope that the people I'm involved with
or support me can just kind of spread
love within that can't keep my hands to
myself the hands to myself singer is
hard at work putting together her
revival tour working on new music and a
new TV series as a producer my mom and I
actually are producing a few projects
together something that we've always
loved to do is creating content that
inspires people that moves people why I
love filmmaking why I love making music
is because it affects people and you
know that's kind of something I've
always wanted to be a part of whether
I'm in it or not I want to make things
great selena is no doubt a busy gal on
Sunday she hung out with her bestie
Taylor and Calvin Harris at the
iHeartRadio Music Awards when is he
gonna set you up so you guys can go on
double dates haha I think that's his
least of his worries no be fun those yes
he's great honestly such a wonderful guy
you